>> Tucker: WELL, IN A
DEVELOPMENT THAT DOESN'T SOUND
REAL AND YOU COULDN'T IMAGINE
WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. WE
TOLD YOU EARLIER IN THE SHOW.
THE HOMELAND SECURITY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY HAS
DECIDED TO CENSOR AMERICANS
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN. THAT IS
NOT THEIR JOB, IT TURNS OUT. THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO THREATEN YOU
TO GET YOU TO SHUT IT UP. THEIR
JOB IS AMONG OTHER THINGS,
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS
HAVE CROSSED AND GANG
AFFILIATIONS, SOME ON A TEAR
WILL WATCH LIST. SO CONGRESSMAN
CHIP REPRESENTS A STATE OF TEXAS
WHERE THIS IS HAPPENING AND
QUESTIONED THE SECRETARY OF DHS
ALEJANDRA MAY WORK US ABOUT WHAT
THE HECK IS GOING ON. HERE IS
PART OF IT.
>> WILL YOU TESTIFY UNDER OATH
RIGHT NOW DO WE HAVE OPERATIONAL
CONTROL YES OR NO?
>> YES, WE DO WITH.
>> WE HAVE OPERATIONAL CONTROL
AT THE BORDERS? WHAT OPERATIONAL
CONTROL AND THE TERM MEANS THE
PREVENTION OF ALL UNLAWFUL
ENTRIES INTO THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING ENTRIES BY TERRORIST,
UNLAWFUL INSTRUMENTS OF
TERRORISM OF NARCOTICS AND
CONTRABAND. HOW ABOUT THE DEAD
BODIES BY MIGRANTS?
>> Tucker: CHIP ROY OF TEXAS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
IF YOU HAVE SEEN A LOT OF KABUKI
IN THESE AND YOU SEEMED
GENUINELY UPSET.
>> I AM UPSET, TUCKER. I
REPRESENT TEXAS AND I SPEND A
LOT OF TIME AT THE BORDER. I WAS
AT DELL RIO A MONTH AGO. I WAS
AT EAGLE PASS THIS MONDAY. I
TALKED TO RANCHERS AND I WATCHED
THE 65-YEAR-OLD RANCHER, TOUGH
TEXAN BREAK DOWN IN TEARS
BECAUSE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
HIS RANCH FINDING DEAD BODIES
AND MIGRANTS ON THE RANCH. I
TALK TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR KIDS TO FENTANYL AND THE
CARTELS ARE HAVING ON THE
BORDER. IF YOUR BLOOD IS NOT
CLOUDED BECAUSE OF DR. FAUCI
THEN IT IS BASED ON WHAT YOU SAW
FROM THE SECRETARY OF ASYLUM AND
AMNESTY. CALLAHAN DROVE
MALLORCA'S BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT
HE IS. HE IS ALLOWING ASYLUM TO
BECOME THE EXCEPTION THAT
SWALLOWS THE RULE OF BORDER
SECURITY AND JAMMING THROUGH
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO FLOOD OURD
OVERWHELMED BORDER PATROL AND Y,
YOUR KIDS ARE THE ONES GETTING
HIT BY IT. THE FENTANYL
THAT IS KILLING PEOPLE IN YOUR
SCHOOLS, THE RANCHES WITH
LIVESTOCK THAT IS DYING. THE
FACT THAT CARTELS ARE MAKING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. YOU
KNOW WHAT, HE'S DOING IT IN THE
FULL NAME OF PASSION. PAT
YOURSELF ON THE BACK AS A GOOD
LIBERAL, COMPASSIONATE
LIBERALISM. I SHOWED HIM
PICTURES OF BODY TRAILS, AND
BROOKS COUNTY, TEXAS WHERE 100
BODIES FOUND. HE DIDN'T EVEN
BLINK. HE DIDN'T BAT AN EYE.
DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR MAYORKAS. HE
KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING. HE'S A
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND
HEAD OF CIA AS DEPUTY DHS
SECRETARY. HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S
DOING. IT IS PURPOSEFUL. THEY
ARE TRYING TO OVERRIDE OUR
BORDER AND OVERWHELM BORDER
PATROL IN THE NAME OF ASYLUM AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE HAD IT
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SPENDING
$30 MILLION TO PROTECT UKRAINE'S
BORDER. AND OBVIOUSLY WE ARE
FOREIGN PATIENTS IF THEY HAPPEN
HERE. DID MAYORKAS SAY ANYTHING
IN RESPONSE? HOW DID HE
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION? ALL HE
SAID HE WAS FOR AMNESTY AND THAT
TELLS YOU A LOT. IN FACT, MORE
THAN AMNESTY COME HE IS FOR
CITIZENSHIP HERE THAT IS A REAL
TELL. HE DIDN'T GIVE A RIP
WHEN I SAID "LOOK MR. SECRETARY,
I TALKED TO BORDER PATROL, YOU
KNOW WHAT 1 MILLION PEOPLE
RELEASED LAST YEAR. IF I DOUBLE
YOUR BORDER, TRIPLE, QUADRUPLE
IT, WITH ECHO UP OR DOWN?" IT
WILL GO UP, WHY BECAUSE YOU ARE
ATTRACTING MORE PEOPLE TO GO
HOME AND ORDER AGENTS WALKED ARM
TO ARM ALL THE WAY TO EL PASO
COME IF YOUR POLICIES ALLOW YOU
TO RELEASE 1 MILLION PEOPLE, YOU
WILL RELEASE MORE. HE KNOWS IT.
HE DOESN'T CARE THAT THAT IS
EMPOWERING CARTELS. THAT IS THE
ACTUAL FACT OF WHAT IS GOING ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
THAT. SECRETARY MAYORKAS DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT YOU. HE CARES ABOUT
FLOODING THE ZONE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND ENDANGERING
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: AT T